عمان اذا همم ربما ضيفنا همم من عمان
الخبير العسكريه عمر الرداد اهلا بك استاذ
الرداد نعود معك الى هذه الحرب المتواصله
في اوكرانيا وهذه المرحله الجديده من هذه
الحرب
وخصوصا في ظل هذا الاجتماع الذي يعقد في
رمشتاين الالمانيه
بحضور وزير الدفاع الامريكي وعدد من وزراء
الدفاع الدول الغربيه الداعمه
هل بدا بهذا الاجتماع
مساء الخير لكي ولاخوه المشاهدين نعم
اعتقد الحرب تجري عبر مراحل متعدده
والفاعل اليوم الرئيسي الذي يحدد فيها هو
حلف الناتو وقراراته وما يقدم من اسلحه
ودعم واضح اوكرانيا اليوم في هذا الاجتماع
الاوروبيين ولا اريد ان اقول فرض مقاربات
ابيما في ذلك الخلاف مع المانيا
الدبابات التي يجري الحوار حولها وهو حوار
في اطار قانون الوحده والصراع بمعنى
الصراع الداخلي بين اطراف التحالف لكنه
بالاطار
همم يتم
اوكرانيا بها اعتقد اننا دخلنا المرحله
الثالثه حتى الان هذه المرحله
همم انها همم تذهب الى الاسلحه الهجوميه
بعد ان انتهينا من المرحله الاولى وهي
التخلص من الاسلحه السودانيه اس
200 منظمات الصواريخ والدبابات ايضا في 72
وهكذا 62 وغيرها همم ثم دخلنا بالمرحله
الثانيه وهي صواريخ باجل واستنجر ثم
ندخل الى الاسلحه الدبابيه الدبابات
الهجوميه
الاوروبيه بالاضافه الى منظمات
الالماني الامريكي حول اشتراك المانيا
بانها لم تزود اوكرانيا
ما لم تزود امريكا
بابنس الامريكيه وحجه امريكا بان ذلك
بالصيانه وبظروف تقنيه خاصه بدبابه ابرامز
سينتهي قريبا وسيتم تزويد اوكرانيا
بالعديد من منظومات الاسلحه والصواريخ
المختلفه وراينا اليوم حجم التبرعات
والدعم لاوكرانيا وهو ما يشبه
علني في تزويدها بالاسلحه نعم فستمر
الرداد في هذه المرحله الجديده من الحرب
وهذا الدعم العسكري المتواصل الغربي
لاكياف ما الذي سيغيره على الارض خصوصا ان
الكريم لان نعلق على هذا الاجتماع فعلا
مؤكدا ان كل هذه الذخائر وهذه الاسلحه لن
تغير في الامر شيئا على الارض
هذا دعايات والاعلانات الصادره من الكريم
اعتقد ان المستهلك والمتلقي فيها هو
المواطن والراي العام الروسي الروس بحاله
انكشاف عسكريه تامه
في ظل الاقمار الصناعيه ومعلومات
استقباريه دقيقه
ويدركون الروس كيف ان تنسيق العمليات ما
بين المدرعات والمدفعيه والطائرات الروسيه
والحرب السمرانيه والالكترونيات التي
يتفوق فيها الغرب بشكل كامل على روسيا
يضربون كيف
فعلت بهم في همم كمان قبل اشهر الان يجري
الحديث يجب الحديث عن شبه جزيره القرم
وتهديدها واستعادتها في رساله استراتيجيه
للروس
بانه ليس المطلوب فقط استحاله المقاطعه
الاربعه التي احتلتها روسيا بل ان المطلوب
العوده الى عام 2014
حدثنا من عمان شكرا جزيلا لك